[Music]
[Music]
meet the husband and wife team selling a
delectable treat on the streets of
bangkok
the couple met six years ago when batuy
was frequenting lex stall they
eventually were married and she joined
his business
today they sell a variety of deep fried
insects near khao san road a popular
tourist area
while their menu may vary their process
is the same so let's start at the
beginning which is actually the end of
the day look come on
foreign
and if you think that all bugs taste the
same
think again
[Music]
eating bugs used to be associated with
poverty in thailand but that's not the
case anymore and it's not just tourists
who enjoy this novel treats
foreign
appreciate most is the support they
provide for each other each and every
day
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
you think of snacks at a ball game you
think hot dogs cracker jacks peanuts
pretzels and of course
grasshoppers
okay maybe you don't but the seattle
mariners and their fans sure do
[Music]
so how did this crunchy critter get a
spot next to your everyday concession
snacks at safeco field it all starts at
this restaurant with this guy my name is
manny arsey i'm the executive chef here
at poquitos
the grasshoppers are grasshoppers you
know they're a delicacy but they're also
a snack i put them on the menu here as a
novelty when we opened and we kind of
just it's been on the menu for almost
six and a half years i'd describe them
uh crunchy like a sunflower seed
salty a little bit spicy
every once in a while you get one that's
a little squishier than you'd like
we just toast them and then we put salt
and some lime and some chili on them and
that's about all we do to them it's one
thing to see restaurant success but
manny's grasshoppers became the
highlight of going to mariners games
when mariners were seen if we'd be a fit
for them i i sent some out the response
was unreal
as in 300 000 plus grasshoppers sold we
were selling out you know before even
the first inning i started off with 50
pounds thinking like oh this will last
us you know a month or two it lasted us
one day to date we've probably gone
through about a thousand pounds
people want more than you know hot dogs
and popcorn and nobody else that had
been doing it at stadium so it's kind of
one of these things that i think people
just really latched on to and the
popularity far exceeded my expectations
[Music]
the creation of the potato chip is a
rather snarky surprising and
idiosyncratic story
when french fries made their way to
america they soon became a restaurant
mainstay many restaurants served fries
as their signature dish believe it or
not they were once considered very hoity
toity in 1853 george crum was a chef at
the moon's lake house in saratoga
springs new york their signature dish
was none other than moon's fried
potatoes or as the aristocrats would say
potatoes served in the french manor one
day just like any other a customer some
believed to have been cornelius
vanderbilt himself ordered fries
upon being served cornelius scoffed and
sent them back
he deemed the fries soggy and not crispy
enough this insanity continued a few
more times until crumb lost it i mean he
really lost it he fired back cutting the
potatoes paper-thin and frying them up
you see back in 1853 eating with your
hands was a major faux pas making crumbs
revenge even more diabolical by cutting
the potatoes paper thin there would be
no way that cornelius could use his fork
forcing him to use his hands krump's
plan backfired kind of as the patrons
dug in with both hands and loved them
saratoga chips were born they became a
saratoga dining staple soon thereafter
they took the world by storm krom
himself even opened his own restaurant
with baskets of chips displayed on each
and every table
[Music]
most people think this fruit smells
terrible
it's been described using words like
rotting onions or raw sewage
not this guy though
[Music]
it's a very good smell to me
[Music]
my name is chang tekseng they call me
duran singh
i'm a farmer until now nearly 30 years
selling durian that's why they call me
durensing
if you're not that familiar with durian
it has a spiky rind and the inside
is a yellow soft colored creamy fruit
it's native to southeast asia and
because of its odor is actually banned
from many public places
durian is forbidden in airport in hotel
some places they put a sign age that no
adult allow
the smell you can't hide my record is
about 100 feet
i can smell durant
[Music]
besides having a distinctive smell
durian also has a distinctive taste it's
like a peanut caramel they have five
flavor
a sweet flavor
alcohol flavor
bitter flavor flour flavor and nam taste
daughter of five flavor
numb taste literally means your mouth
will go numb
wow i can feel the numbness freshly
dropped durant the flavor is so good
even the bees come to the durian this
may well be my new favorite fruit people
in general are divided on this fruit
those who love it
love it the durian is so tasty it's
really good it's much better than it
smells
if you really like durant
there can be
like some people may look like crazy
like breakfast lunch dinner three meals
are all durant they can eat five seven
fruits per day
and there are others who just can't get
past the smell
i smell like or what they chase
for durian sang it is the perfect fruit
either you like it or you hate it
some people they don't give chance to
taste
but you've got to try once in your
lifetime
[Music]